- It's not bad news, okay?
I do have something to tell you though.
We've been doing this for
three years and I mean,
I'm sure you've noticed,
I'm usually not in front of the camera,
and I mean, I did that for a reason,
I don't, I prefer to
stay behind the camera.
Basically, what I'm trying to say
is that I'm doing something
that is completely
outside my comfort zone,
I'm starting a podcast and in the podcast
I'm always going to be in
them because I'm the host.
I've been wanting to start
a podcast for like two years
and just my fear of being in
front of the camera stopped me.
I get a lot of comments saying,
"Thoraya, you should start a podcast.
I love just listening to your
videos on my drive to work
or like when I'm doing laundry,
I just put my headphones in and I listen."
And I'm just like, "Dang,
I wish I wasn't so nervous
in front of the camera so I
could actually make a podcast."
But that's what I'm doing now,
I'm getting over my fears.
Let me tell you why
it has been so hard for
me to start a podcast,
even though I've been wanting
to do it for two years.
Well, first of all, I'm the type of person
where if I wanna do something,
I just like do it right away.
This thing of like wanting to
do this and not being able to
it's been like eating away
at me for a really long time,
so I just got to the
point where I don't know,
I was just like, "I preach
this whole being-bold thing,
why can't I just be a
little bold and do this?"
But yeah, let me get back to why
it's so hard to do a podcast.
I'm a pretty shy person,
until you get to know me, of course,
but like, when people tell me like,
"Wow you must be so outgoing,
you meet so many people."
I just think to myself, "Little
do you know." (chuckles)
But the thing is like,
when you have a passion for something
you're willing to like grind through
things that hold you back.
I rely heavily on skills
that I've just practiced
over and over again,
I've just always felt
like to be a podcast host,
you just have to be like naturally gifted
and able to ignore the camera
and the fact that you're being recorded.
And if the person for example,
my worst fear is like to have a guest on
who says the most amazing story
and I just reply in a really dumb way
and I'm just like, "Do I put
this episode up and look dumb?
Or do I not put it up and
just lose this amazing story?"
So I don't know, it's just,
it's been a lot of overthinking
and a lot of fear that's
been holding me back
but obviously we're here
because I finally did it,
that's the good news. (chuckles)
I do wanna warn you guys though,
this is something where
I'm learning as I go,
like I could've just
like practiced on my own
for a really long time,
gotten really good at
it and then launched it,
but I just thought it would
be cool to get your feedback
as I look super awkward
in front of the camera
and like, I don't know,
I guess it'll be fun to look
back on my first episode,
once we're like 100 episodes in.
I've been trying to figure
out a way to announce it
and I thought, why not
just do what I'm best at?
Being in front of the camera,
that's sarcasm. (chuckles)
And I don't know what it is
about you guys, honestly,
like you just have some sort of magic.
I know a lot of people say this,
that they have the best subscribers,
but I'm like, I think I'm
being completely unbiased
when I say that, "No, I
have the best subscribers."
I'm still a hot mess, but I
was even more of a hot mess
before you guys, so let
me thank you for that,
but I'm saying all of this to say
that I know how powerful
your kindness can be
because I've lived it firsthand
for the past three years
and I guess what I'm trying to ask is
whatever magic it is that you guys do
and have done from my YouTube channel,
I hope you'll consider
also working that magic
for my podcast, 'cause I do
wanna give it a solid shot,
I don't wanna do it, see
that it's not going so well
and kind of give up on the idea.
And I know that the only way
I could give it a solid shot
is if we all go into it together.
I don't want to half-ass it,
I want to see if we can actually do it.
So if you don't mind,
I'm going to list a few
things that you could do
to best help launch my podcast.
It's going to launch January 12th
and I guess the first step is, listen?
Hopefully you'll love
it, but if you hate it,
please let me know in
private that you hate it,
because I might be a little
fragile the first few episodes,
but if you love it and
you think to yourself,
"You know what, I'm gonna work my magic."
Then, these are the things
that will help most.
First, leave a five-star
review on Apple Podcasts.
I don't know why this is so important
but everyone keeps telling me like,
"Tell people to leave
you a five-star review."
The podcast is gonna be
available everywhere, basically,
like Spotify, Anchor, Google
Podcasts and a lot of others
and of course, following and
subscribing on them will help,
but the most important thing,
it's really important
to get a lot of five-star
reviews on Apple Podcasts
and so I thought we would
have some fun with it.
If you decide to leave a five-star review,
I thought it would be cool for
you to answer this question,
who's one stranger you still remember?
So under a five-star
review on Apple Podcasts,
answer the question, who's one
stranger you still remember?
I'll read through every
single one, I promise.
Even if there are 10,000,
I'm gonna read through every single one.
I'm gonna choose some to
share on my Instagram Story,
so leave your Instagram handle as well
if you want me to tag you
and of course, obviously
subscribing and following
on whatever platform you listen on
or all of them if you wanna go all out.
And even though the podcast
launches on the 12th
I actually have my trailer
and my profile up now,
so you can start doing
all these things today.
I'll make sure to have
my podcast's links in the description.
Another thing I think would really help
is to share the podcast
with someone you think would love it.
So if you listen to the podcast
and it makes you think of
someone you think would love it,
send it to them.
For every episode, every single
one, just send it to people.
We're gonna learn as we go.
We're gonna grow as we go
and how sick would it be if
we made like the top charts?
Can you imagine?
Oh my God.
I don't really have any, like, goals.
I don't know.
I mean, it would to make
like the top charts,
but I feel that's just so out there,
I don't even know if that's possible
but I guess that could be a goal.
Okay, you know what?
When I had 300 subscribers
I made it a goal to hit a million
and I thought it was
impossible at the time.
So let's do the same again right now.
Obviously, it's not about the numbers,
but as a creator, it is
cool to get more people
to see what you make,
to hear what you make,
so I try to limit the amount of times
I put number goals out there
but it is fun to do every once in a while
just so you can look back and be like,
"Oh my gosh, I can't
believe that happened."
And also I'll be posting
the video version on the,
I didn't even tell you guys
what the podcast is about,
oh my God.
Okay, do you wanna know?
Let me tell you what the podcast is about.
It's actually super exciting.
Okay, I want the podcast to be
a podcast version of my channel
and how I thought was best to do this
is for me to set up two
chairs, two microphones,
and two cameras, of course, in public,
on sidewalks, at parks.
I sit on one chair and the
other chair is for my guest
who has to be a stranger that
I meet on the spot that day,
I get them in the chair
and I have them answer
the questions you've seen on my channel,
I get them to tell me their secrets,
I get them to do something bold
like maybe call their crush.
And I guess the only difference
between my podcast and my channel
is that you get to know these
strangers on a deeper level.
I didn't think that was
possible, but it turns out it is.
For example, on my channel,
you see like 30 strangers per episode
and at most maybe one of their
segments is two minutes long.
So now just imagine that one stranger
who has a two-minute segment on my episode
now has an entire hour.
I know you'll fall in
love with these people
because I've been falling in
love with them and their story.
It's just been like a shift
in the way I do things.
Before, I would just meet
someone for a couple of minutes,
maybe we'd talk for like 5
to 10 minutes off camera,
if they were willing,
but this is just like,
I've become friends with
almost every single person
who I've interviewed so far,
so it's been pretty cool.
And another cool thing is
I'll have follow-up episodes,
I'm sure you guys will,
based on the stories I've heard so far,
you guys are gonna want
to know follow-ups.
Other things I'm considering
doing for the podcast
is this thing called Thoraya's voicemail.
If you guys follow me on Instagram,
you'll see that I have
this number you can call in
and leave a secret for my voicemail
and this might be like bonus audio
at the end of each episode,
but I'll play basically,
a bunch of voicemails from
you guys sharing your secrets.
There's just so many,
there's so much I wanna do
and I think the more I overcome my fears,
the more freedom I'll
have to be able to do this
and that's really exciting
and nerve-racking.
It's like a mixture of
such opposite feelings,
I'm super excited but super nervous,
super stressed but super
anxious in a good way,
I don't know, it just,
it's been an interesting couple of months
leading up to this, but
yeah, that's what it's about.
I mean, this video is
really all over the place,
if you're still here,
thank you. (chuckles)
I think that's it, I think
that's all I wanted to say.
Did I even tell you?
I didn't even tell you guys
what it's called, oh my God.
This is the worst announcement video ever.
The podcast is called, oh my gosh,
the podcast is called, how
perfect I have it right here.
Okay, so here is the big reveal.
I didn't even plan on
having this be a big reveal,
it was just 'cause I forgot
to tell you, (chuckles)
but now it's a big reveal.
I'm gonna reveal the name
but let me go over all
these things one more time.
January 12th, the podcast
is going to launch,
each episode will air every Tuesday.
The video version will
air a few days later
on my YouTube channel.
Listen to the podcast first,
try to imagine what you
think the guests look like
and then come on my YouTube channel
maybe before you watch the video,
leave a comment guessing what you think
that they would look like,
share the podcast with your friends
and then obviously, the
most important thing,
leave a five-star review
on Apple Podcasts.
I'll make sure to link
everything in the description.
Okay, so now for the big reveal.
I'll reveal the name and we'll end this
with a preview of the podcast.
The podcast is going to
be called "Hey, Stranger!"
Is that in focus?
There it is.
That's pretty much it, thank
you guys for everything,
I love you so much and
we'll meet on January 12th,
the day my podcast launches.
(clapperboard snaps)
(gentle music)
"Hey, Stranger!" (chuckles)
Hello to everyone listening.
My name is Thoraya, this is
the "Hey, Stranger!" podcast
and before we start, let
me set the scene for you.
I'm currently sitting in
a chair at my local park
which also happens to be
one of the biggest tourist
attractions in my city.
Across from me is an empty chair
and on today's and every episode
that empty chair will be filled one by one
by people of different backgrounds,
mindsets and walks of life.
The only criteria is
that they are a stranger.
(joyful music)